today me and all these boys are playing
3d among us
we have dreams we have jacksepticeye we
have george we have sapnap we have
wildcat we have laser beam we have
everyone playing i just want to let you
know that this game is not available
publicly this right here danny is the
creator of 3d among us
go to his channel it'll be linked in
description subscribe
[Music]
you know this is awesome i want to see
him kill i didn't get imposter
the lights make it so much more ominous
this is really weird to see people in 3d
where is okay i'm doing what am i doing
alrighty boys
not imposter though well oh we're on
polish over on polis
carl's in here okay call be nice let me
stay with wildcat
everyone is a big 3d bean
no dream killed me that's kind of
suspicious bro
dead body reported that was fast i was
doing lava with dream
and uh snap nap and dream literally
shank snap knob's head off in front of
me
what that lit that makes no sense i saw
it with my own two eyes you're saying
i'm doing okay you said you said
i'm doing lava with you and then i kill
somebody right in front of you for no
reason yeah
i didn't see anything because i had the
panel open but danny's literally lying
why don't we just pick
dreamer danny and then vote the other
one out next round i want to vote on
dreams
no no no no vote danny vote danny i made
this game you can you can trust me boys
out of respect danny made the game so
dreams gotta go first we'll vote david
that's enough for me oh my gosh
i think danny just knew if he could pin
it on dream that everyone would follow
suit getting
out of here boys you could have even
been proven and i would have voted you
in the soup he goes
all right well uh my imposter teammate
died instantly all right so one of the
imposters is god
i don't know why i did that i didn't see
him oh lord
oh no when lights go off in this this is
this is way scarier than my lights go
off normally
this is the lab over here and just go
ahead and kill you
okay let's go fix the lights oh it's so
dark no
all right let's go fix the lights yeah
hey jack how's it going we're fixing
lights there it is who fixed them carol
fixed them this is bizarre
here let me help you carl that'll help
there you go
oh you jerk i was fixing my settings ew
i look like a toilet all right i'm just
going looking for bodies
let me find a task i want to do one all
right there's a couple there's a whole
gang in here what is happening here
hey wildcat laser beam why are there
four people down huh
all righty let's just call the lights oh
no the lights
oh dead body and electrical wait a
minute
wait all right well it's not me i agree
also it is not me
i would like the third that it's not me
who found the body let's start with that
i found the body it was on the lights
panel in my experience wildcat
doing this with mr beast he's always
imposter not as super sauce
oh my god i swear to god i you have no
proof
it's very sauce you think you can invite
us here to play this
and then kill us all it's not even close
honestly i'm voting you out just for
making me wake up early
get him out here i just would like to
say you guys are all
stupid i hated that guy anyway well
that's not very good
uh i thought it was mr beast okay maybe
it's chandler chandler hasn't said a
damn thing this whole time they just
voted me out for no reason
i did nothing well i'm almost done with
my tasks i haven't done a single task
it might be laser i'm just gonna say
it's chandler
oh no bro okay you're kidding me
anyone dead anywhere i feel dumb don't
kill me
don't kill me hey mr septic guy how you
doing
well i'm dead over here guys come on oh
god lights are out
oh i thought i was about to get murdered
let's see who it is i came up to jack he
was just kind of
standing around walking around i don't
know what he was doing so i feel like
jack killed but i don't know
oh interesting mr wildcat because i said
i was 100 clear
i also said that i believe jack i
believe jack
thank you i'm skipping but i think it's
jack honestly because i kind of want to
get murdered in three days i want to see
what that's like
that would be pretty cool yeah stick
around jack and it'll happen for sure
all right laser babe you want to get
mutted do ya
murder me i want to see what it feels
like i think it's wild cat it's either
wildcat or dany
i don't believe that it's laser beam
it's jack
it's jacked everybody's super grouped
listen i'm gonna try and win this
yes come kill me please i'm all done
where's laser
why is it so hard to get killed nowadays
yes i died
oh that's unfortunate wait i saw you
doing when the door opened
to be fair all i was doing was filling
lasers requests so actually i'm the good
guy in this scenario
get him out of here laser how was
getting murdered in 3d was that pretty
cool oh that was sick
dude all right let's run it back
i'm so nervous i don't know what to do
so now this round i'm going to follow
somebody yeah we're not imposter that's
fine well i'm never going to get him
pasta
why am i never imposter i'm going on my
own
chandler's been imposter a lot today so
i'll probably follow him around
is he gonna kill oh no he's got me
i'm an idiot dream one less person that
can do tasks
ladies and gentlemen i've witnessed a
murder first
hand who was it i just get off the task
turning my right and i see a blood
splatter in a white
half body sitting there and then i look
around and i see chandler running away
fleeing did you write that down just so
you could read it when you're imposter
if it's not chandler we vote wild yep
fine please vote him out next
there's no voting me out next because
it's gonna say it was an imposter i'm
sorry yay
dang it i still say vote mr beast out
because it's funny lights are out i'm
already on the way to the lights
you know what i don't care about the
lights this is next level strats you
just don't care about the lights and you
just go and do your tasks i'm telling
you guys
he's following me stop a dream
dream he was the imposter i feel like
whoever's impostor just killed someone
oh i just saw danny alive like two
seconds ago hey look at that yeah no
this is actually a great button because
i have some info it can't be george
it can't be me and it can't be you if
you're at the button he died like
outside med bay and it can't be me
because i was figuring out how to start
the engine so that leaves one person
it's either jack dreams sapnap or laser
a justice for mr bass
yeah get jack out of here okay if you
want your youtube title
this is just for your behavior in
previous rounds yeah honestly
just get them out of here no oh i am
shocked it's completely fine listen to
how mr b says it's fine jimmy yellow
scammer
the dream there goes the lights no one's
gonna die fire lights going out on me
where are the lights we got gonna do my
temperature task
i know it's dream finish my tasks i
think now i've earned the right to go
look at some
cameras i'm going to be big brain and
call the button dream is suss
dream is hella sauce for sure how am i
suss i was trying to do your sauce on
the last kill you're suss on the last
kill
zap knap what is the meaning behind this
button i was trying to be big brain
that's
snap sap nappy up for wasting a button
yeah you failed honestly we should
execute him for it no no no no so i'll
do this
i already voted for dream but i'm down
it's dream it's dream
no he's imposter oh wait oh crap no
hug me laser hug me too well at least i
finished all my tasks so i can watch
everybody
we did say no stacking but we're gonna
stack apparently let's move together
group group group yeah i'm just gonna go
i'll let him motor
finally starting to learn where
everything is running the lights
sprinting the lights
you're joking mr beast and dream
together
no i don't like this one there's no way
he gets away with it there's no way he
gets away with it
what is going on right here what is
going on right here oh get away from me
done done tasks yes i'm a good crewmate
i'm
dead
you're just going to kill one more
person right not
dream die oh can't see anything was that
a person i saw hello
it is me septic man see if we can find a
body back here
no no thank you
oh he got him
he's dropped to the corner again
audience specimen maybe oh no dreams
protecting mr beast he won't let anyone
hurt him
hey i hope he goes called the meeting i
don't want to call him anything
oh oh that's unfortunate did anybody die
oh yeah no definitely somebody died so
we did not have four people george died
who is the last to say george
i do have a little bit of information
early on in the round i saw
dream and mr beast making out hard their
lips locked
i was with mr bass i'd say at least 70
of this round probably
i don't think it was dream we were
together
majority of the time i think it's laser
i called it i called the vote out
chandler so you know it's not me
wait wait no then it's dream or mr basin
like what is this
well we were the guy the whole time mr
beast didn't kill there's no way this
was killed george because i was with him
the whole time
so then it's wildcat to me it's either
dream or laser beam because i don't
think it's beast literally
can't be me bro i've been doing my
target i mean literally can't be you it
definitely can uh wildcat or laser pick
your pick your take your pick
i i'm going to go with laser yeah vote
me i want you guys to lose
oh no oh no it's stream
stream just do laps do laps jimmy
wow gg
no darn it was that the first 3d
marination
i think it was they were making out so
hard even i got marinated dude